do you ever wonder about the route your
plane takes
or if it could take a faster one
currently aircraft
are not always permitted to take the
shortest route resulting in longer
more polluting flights single europe
european sky
must bring direct routes
from a to b not taking in account
the ground borders of the member states
but to have a schengen on the sky
so for the passengers will mean
shorter flights less delays and of
course
less emissions while the common airspace
management program has been around for
decades
it needs updating to fit the green deal
climate goals
for the first time in this regulation
we'll
introduce a climate eu-wide performance
target which means up to 10 percent
reduction of emissions meps have called
for a more open market
european countries should remain free to
choose their air traffic service
providers
but only after a fair and open tendering
process
this will help improve air traffic
control weather and communication
services
while keeping costs down i hope that
now after so many years
the service providers understood
that they need to to
change themselves because you cannot
stop
the progress technology is coming
digitalization is coming
the space technology is coming which
means that
they need to adapt to this progress
with the single european sky parliament
wants eu airspace to become less
fragmented
and more efficient